whoa that was a quick change right there
nate
all right good wednesday morning
everybody beautiful skies out there with
some mid-level clouds but also we've got
the haze and smoke which is not too
pretty and it's certainly not good to be
breathing that in the air is really dry
16 percent humidity 80 degrees in the
middle of town but we've got some
neighborhoods that are in the 70s so
feels pretty comfortable out there
really it's just not good air to be
breathing 607 is the sunrise and 7 17 is
the sunset the air quality advisory for
smoke has been extended through today
unhealthy levels of smoke and elevated
ozone expected through the afternoon
that's thanks to the smoke as well as
these extra hot temperatures which will
again reach the above normal triple
digits and we have even more heat coming
to finish the week tomorrow and friday
wildfire smoke it contains really
very fine pollutants which can be very
irritable to your throat your eyes
it can give you headaches and even make
you sick at your stomach and can be even
damaging to your lungs so you just
really want to take it slow not spend
too much time outdoors if you don't have
to the fires are still just burning
incredibly some of them are hard to get
a containment on them the calder fire is
the one that's been exploding over the
last 10 days our own nevada national
guard aviators have been helping with
this fire now this was some video they
posted yesterday of air drops water
drops from the air
this fire is growing so fast and now
it's marching towards the tahoe basin
it's already consumed more than 450
homes
and now it's headed towards tahoe which
there's thousands and thousands of homes
up there so this fire has become the
national priority to get this fire under
control it's only a little more than 10
percent contained right now 120 plus
thousand acres so we've got more heat
coming for us with heat warnings now for
the lake the river and all the way down
the colorado river valley for thursday
and friday as we'll look for
temperatures along the river to reach
one teens or the end of the week 104 for
the valley today southwest winds up to
about 25 miles an hour again breezy in
the afternoon like we've had a lot
recently and then more heat thursday
friday saturday look at that 107 108 the
record's 110 for those days so we'll be
real close to it next week as we finish
august head into september we'll back
off a little on the heat but the monsoon
moisture comes back and john will be
looking for slight chances of
thunderstorms as we get into tuesday and
the first of september